j'ai reçu une lettre c'était pas ya un
mois peut-être c'était là et je me suis
déçue j'ai encore fait huissier de
justice bim veuillez nous suivre
monsieur hanouna par ici la sortie les
menottes binebine titre est en fait ça
vient d'une vieille histoire où gilles
verdez avais parlé ici du coup de
l'émission les z'amours
et je vous le dis on va être mise en
examen et gilbert des moines - tribunal
correctionnel
c'est une histoire de ouf on vous résume
tout ça c'est plus challengé l'halluciné
dans mystery vous allez halluciner rien
c'est pas la lettre commence comme ça
par monsieur en application de l'article
51 de la loi du 29 juillet 1881 je vous
en vue fort je vous informe que
j'envisage votre mise en examen olala ça
veut dire que pour ce que vous allez
voir là il ya quand même des gars qui
veulent nous mettre en examen
voilà bon je pense que la juge est assez
intelligente pour dire voilà c'est ça
une histoire ripoux mais regardez bien
c'est quand même ouf voilà
regardez où je vous halluciné la regarda
mise en examen voilà une information qui
risque d'en laisser plus d'un bouche bée
cyril hanouna a été mis en examen par le
tribunal de grande instance de paris
oui mis en examen vous avez bien entendu
une histoire aussi absurde que
rocambolesque qu'on vous raconte
c'est la société sony pictures qui a
décidé d'attaquer en justice l'animateur
en raison d'une séquence diffusée en
2010 81 pmp ce jour de février gilles
verdez et sur le plateau de l'émission
un scoop en poche
alors qu'il était question des tarifs
des émissions de télé le chroniqueur
partagent une information qui lui est
parvenue selon laquelle les producteurs
de l'émission les z'amours vendre l
émission soixante dix mille euros par
jour à france 2 un tarif
particulièrement élevé car selon les
informations de gilles verdez l'émission
ne coûterait en réalité que 10000 euros
à produire selon ces chiffres
sony pictures réalise
et donc une marge conséquente sur cette
émission mais cette révélation n'a
pourtant pas plu à tout le monde plutôt
que de s'adresser à cyril ou à la
production de l'émission tpm p les
producteurs d amour ont décidé d'en
appeler directement à la justice
monsieur je vous informe que j'envisage
votre mise en examen pour avoir porté
des allégation ou imputation de faits
portant atteinte à l'honneur ou à la
considération de la société sony
pictures télévision production france
sachant que le jeu n'a pas été arrêtée
par la direction de france télé et
qu'aucune conséquence n'a été
consécutives à ces déclarations
difficile de comprendre la colère qui
pousse sony pictures a attaqué en
justice cyril hanouna deux ans après la
divulgation de cette info médias alors
c'était un max et acer faut carrément
sais pas où mme banon benjamin castaldi
très dangereux parce que si vous étés
bien examen pour cette histoire là on
est tous à 13 en danger alors non
information j'ai zéro téléspectateurs
c'est ce qu'ont montré ça ridicule
devant les tribunaux sont encombrées
n'ont pas autre chose à faire que vous
mettre en examen les sortes
d'informations sur les amours c'est
ridicule il ya eu des conséquences aux
informations données
je crois pas a maintenant les yeux ronds
mise en jeu laissez les producteurs d
amour qui nous attaque et qui qui me met
en examen
donc pour vous dire un mot des mises ont
pas de grand chose à faire je pense
qu'ils sont pas débordés par la
production d amour pour faire ça ce
serait mettre en examen tous les gens
qui nient destruction méchante c'est
sympa puisque puisque ce français laisse
énoncé un peu quelque part les impôts ce
qui se passe aux échéances à venir ce
que tu fais c'est puisqu'ils vous
attaque mais elles sont adonnés faux
montant maintenant moi j'ai envie de
savoir qui vous attaquent hockey aller
au tribunal
ça me dérange pas mais kevin
je retournerai dans mon camion ça me
dérange pas mais maintenant je veux
savoir les vraies monte en moi ça
m'intéresse pas vraiment en agate bâche
est vrai ils les ont jamais donné mal de
nenê 1 mais regarde apparemment ils ont
été très très très très peiné par par la
sortie de gilles mais est ce que la
production a essayé de contacter notre
production a essayé de vous contacter
directement un examen justice non mais
bon alors franchement la série du
tournoi qui sera prêt début mai des
résultats des courses à vapeur qui
dépendait et tous il a rien et vous sony
pictures donc c'est la production d
amour voilà et franchement ils n'ont
rien à faire là j'ai cette date de 2018
nice même passé quelque chose entre les
blocs pas du tout on a même fait un
petit rectificatif
mais voilà apparemment voilà et c'est
cautionner par france télé sectionné par
france télé bien entendu je ne pense pas
que sinon je pense pas c'est la
conviction la dépendance et la
production mais mine de rien je pense
que france télé devrait intervenir et
bien sûr leur dire que ces voix là c'est
quand même qu'il ait pas eu dans les
andes et n'osent que que sony pictures
voilà calme le truc mais bon écoutez si
on doit aller s'expliquer devant la juge
je me ferais un plaisir d'aller
expliquer avec gilles verdez ça me fait
un peu chier detec gibert les sportifs
ivoiriens s'il faut le faire on le fera
on regardera pas là mais rejetant mal
gardé l'amour âge
regardez pas de suite ridicule qui
retrouvent un emploi à la crème 9 %
trouvent pas ridicule oui non je pense
qu'on aura pas de suite parce que votre
émission c'est une parodie quelque part
d'un paysage audiovisuel et la parodie
vis-à-vis des tribunaux sont là faut
mettre laurent gerra vous m camp
mulhousien de tribunes là c'est vraiment
c'est une pionnière munich sans vote ont
eu bat donc sachez le voilà je suis mise
en examen voilà les raisons visage de
mettre en doute son chômage à cause de
cette séquence aller